ça commence là ça commence la regarde ça
commence bien brigitte mâcon oui à les
bruits allaient brigitte super nanny ça
lui va bien les cheveux tirés comme ça à
ces bonsoir et bienvenue à tous ensemble
soit en clair
bonsoir gilles bonsoir à tous j'aime pas
j'aime pas j'aime pas j'aime pas j'aime
pas ça pardon oui dupont aignan bas il
est là dupont-aignan nicolas dupont
benoît hamon quel président voulait vous
êtes qui ça c'est le stagiaire
il n'était pas dans six dans le c'est
l'assistant de la gale s'ils étaient
dans les vacances de l'amour mais non
c'est pas l'apprentissage en français
c'est l'apprentissage du français
paddock ta gueule dans l'école a plié à
l'adie du au lieu de le la priorité de
l'excellent invité mystère c'est la vie
et là il va poser des questions à un
moment un des présidentiables sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy on
reconnaît voilà assez d'accord n'est pas
aussi violent
un homme si un homme clean un homme
honnête je vais vous dire qu'à redresser
la france en cinq ans sarkozy y est
toujours ainsi à cracher dessus alors
qu'on se rende de françois hollande
bravo dès qu'ils sont tous habillés
pareil le costume de filles en brie plus
le pot 1 personne écoute mais non
l'écoutent pas quoi
emmanuel macron dans votre programme
programme première vague de gilles
boulet emmanuel macron dans votre
programme c'est pas mal quand je
construit pendant ce temps là nicolas
dupont aignan passe du bon temps et
cyril hanouna
y'en a vraiment qui ont la belle vie
talmi s'il avait été au gouvernement ça
aurait été autre chose lui alourdir la
du maquereau gouvernement tu le mets un
an et demi à bercy ça c'est con
là dedans j'ai mis entre les yeux et
c'était pas facile parce que vraiment
ils se touchent rien sur twitter c'est
un peu une petite affaire qui est sorti
sur fion qu'il n'allait serre entre
elles ou [__] doit peut-être lui dit
oui à tout le monde d'accord
mais quelqu'un pareil que oui et en fait
à mon avis il écouterait la chanson
c'est pas mes filles il faut imposer
fifi ouais ouais mais vous savez moi
chaque fois que vous admiriez si c'était
bien là donc vraiment un million en solo
auquel mureaux veut faire un bisou vas-y
mon mari et moi je lui ai dit je veux
revenir sur fait c'est qui attend il met
à nouveau à 12 heures et 8 heures tu me
dégoûtes nous dégoûter à gerber tu es à
gerber tu me donnes tu me débecte ferme
la ferme ta gueule tu me dégoûtes ans ma
mère
votez mâcon je cherchais une bien j'en
profite pour tuer une bière qu'elle sait
j'ai raté un truc de ouf macro et
d'équité de droite non mélenchon et
avons ils ont fait d'alliance nantais
tout pkoi fillon l'a dit je rembourse
tous ces bons chiffres n'ont il est
parti en loge de l'artiste échec c'est
un truc de malade et vous dire de la
merde
vous devriez arriver de voter pour une
république bienveillante une république
moi j'aurais aimé voter pour une
république malveillantes comme comment
faire de voter pour un futur désirable
mais non je veux savoir indésirables
yahoo n'a pas de candidat du coup
la solution c'est peut-être de voter
françois hollande encore un nouveau